今日は外れ冊をで長は何日かスっていますか
今日は4月のついたつエイプリルフールでございます今まずはきっと車に乗ってるん
ですけどもうちょっと彼にとびっきりのドッキリチックな嘘をついてやろうと思います
ただに結構計画的に塗ってきてるんでタブをすると思うんですけども来なければ
レンタカーレンタカーで車を借りて今このな
に雅紀のなんかね財布とか鞄とかいろんなものが入っていますね今から真っ先につぶっ
厩舎の企画を言ってっまた二人で旅行動画旅動画を車で取ろうと
か決まっている車の鍵車だかに持っている座席に置いてなかった
なったでまさに迎えに行く徹底だかなーっていうわけで今から旅動画とるわけなんです
けれども
恥ずかしいハグさせて完成正木何か買いに行ってて
声聞こえないここを抜け際に入ってて9するはナイフ
サーフィン下げていませんまだ1車で旅道具は揃って話を全てにまだ2尾動画をと
るってから思い込んでいますが家でもオープニングとレッツって一人で言うんですけど
もう根源の客はエンターかパクられるドッキリでございまーすぺンターってとこが
ちょっと怖いですよね
後輩2人と連絡をとってましてもうすぐこの近くにきます
もしもし
ポジションに就いたあーあおけば釣れ区レンタカー通すわかれうたちょっとまたライン
ライドしたら車入ってきて
by good luck てみたいな仕掛け人で後輩を2で読んでてその後輩2人に
泥棒役をやってもらいます俺たちが使うこの車が盗まれて運転されてブート入っちゃっ
たらどういう反応するのか
松戸 f リフィルなんでねちょっとドキッとさせたいわけですよ
だけどもう
まさにが入ってくるんでちょっとまずは音外でオープニングを取りますオープニング
撮ってる間に勝手にこの車が動き出して言っちゃうっていう勃起です
この念入りに話で起こしますええええと移動するルートなんだけど
信号に行って欲しいんじゃね左のそれだったら俺がそれほど走れたらいい所済みの方
ああ朝からよろしくお願いしますんだけど薄までくれば走る俺
厚膜するません果たしてどうなるのでしょうか4個スタートなんだけど
普通に入ったあああ
こういったナレーターに来れば抜け全体ます
本当にこれで撮るこの後から入っていいかべき身体くらい待たせたのだがそれでいきま
しこ
ブランデーおかしいけどそれじゃあ肇社長とまたキッズに春休みも終わりですよ
終わりますねおっとしーわー
で出かけてないと思うかちょっとねはるやすみなさい5ぐらいはねまたきっと軽く
ドライブチックなちょっと落ち着いと動画をフォローかなと思います
せっかくの休みなんで今日は添えですみましょうはい
ん
ちょっと待っててねこの後居場所を言わなきゃいけ
鳥ず両手が空いてで凍ったりが1場所なんですけどもう
足利ていくのですっ
sony 入っていません
持っています
俺だついていません
ああああああ
ちょっと面白さ
スバルクレバス走るをれ困惑する魔石
音はれて困る受けきっ
早く警察呼ぶぞ
me
ブーブーイヤー
goo
パッチ r 中にある自分のものを考えてはっはっはっいう
持ってくれなってくるんだよ白茶抹茶いやーいい顔ねほんとにうわぁ
コンヴェント夫バッハ
me
wh
ni ん
ダボ
オープン
wobble